hello there guys we have some exciting
new details regarding the book of boba
fett which releases december of this
year so let's get straight into it
so tamara morrison did an interview with
rotten tomatoes and he says we're going
to see boba fett's past and where he's
been since the empire strikes back
someone pointed out he's being kind of
stuck in this one place and now is the
time to actually go back in time
and check out his journey to find out
more about him also they brought robert
back in to direct it through more
so there's some wonderful directors
involved alright guys so there's a
couple things to unpack here so firstly
morrison says that we're actually going
to see boba fett
uh where he's been since the empire
strikes back so we're going to see more
of him during the time of the original
trilogy which
um makes me think so the show is called
the book of boba fett
will we see this show have a similar
structure to a book
what i mean is chapters so will each
chapter of the
book of mandalorian be a different story
or a different
r or will it just be one continuous
story so potentially the first couple
chapters could be his experiences um
during the original trilogy from the
empire strikes back to return of jedi
potentially another chapter could be him
and how he escaped the sarlacc pit and
finally the other chapters could be
about his experiences
after the mandalorian season 2 because i
remember reading somewhere that the book
of boba fett
is seen as the mandalorian season 2.5
and also apparently some mandalorian
characters are going to make cameos in
the show
because of all this i don't think this
whole show is just going to be him
in his time since the empire strikes
back i think we're eventually going to
see
stuff um after the mandalorian season
two so potentially the show is going to
have a lot of time jumps or it could
have a structure where
boba fett's recounting events in his
past he's kind of like
writing a book or it's like a journal so
each chapter each episode is a new entry
of boba fett recount and experiences
that have happened to him
anyway another thing to unpack from this
interview is that multiple directors
have been indirectly confirmed for their
show because morrison said robert will
be back to direct a few episodes
so this confirms that robert fromm
season two of the mandalorian who
directed the boba fett episode is back
to direct more
but he said it's only back to director
through more so this inadvertently
um confirms they're going to be more
directors also because we assume some
episodes are going to be set um during
the original trilogy
could we see the return of some
characters such as bosk
ig-88 dengar or even vader himself
anyway guys that's about it for this
video so please let me know what you
think in the comment section below
and what do you think we'll see from the
book of boba fett
[Applause]
[Music]